accueil des réfugiés
bono mise à jour
j'ai été bien occupé et ça veut dire que
certaines nouvelles sont passées sous le
radar c'est donc l'occasion de joindre
mes collègues marie hélène tremblay et
yves malo de nos bureaux parlementaire
de québec et d'ottawa
bon dimanche à vous deux dangers je
commence avec vous on a appris cette
semaine que l'ex premier ministre harper
a fait une série de nominations
partisanes tout juste avant sa défaite
rien on va dire pour calmer le cynisme
des gens vers la politique
voilà c'est même tout juste avant la
campagne électorale et c'est le site
internet ipad les textes qui a dévoilé
que stephen harper fait ces quarante
neuf nominations à l'avance parce que
c'était des gens qui étaient déjà en
poste dont le mandat qui prenait fin
généralement en novembre ou décembre et
un autre dont le mandat se termine en
mais tous ces mandats ont été prolongées
d'emblée vous savez qu'un premier
ministre procède à des nominations afin
de régime en nommant des amis à certains
postes ça c'est vu fréquemment mais là
il a poussé le cynisme plus loin en
liant quelque sorte les mains au nouveau
gouvernement en procédant ces
nominations qui sont essentiellement des
tribunaux administratifs des conseils
d'administration les conservateurs s'en
défendent en disant que c'était pour
assurer le bon fonctionnement de l'état
il est permis d'en douter pour plusieurs
avoir à l'usure marie-hélène de votre
côté les travaux parlementaires de
l'assemblée nationale vont se terminer
le vendredi prochain
blitz est commencé mais il ya beaucoup
de choses qui sont passés inaperçus
comme l'adoption d'un important projet
de loi visant à renforcer la lutte
contre le tabagisme
effectivement et c'est à l'unanimité que
les parlementaires ont adopté cette loi
qui n'avait pas été révisé depuis quand
même plus de dix ans est ce qu'on veut
essentiellement bien sûr c'est prévenir
le tabagisme auprès des jeunes parce que
chaque semaine emmanuel il ya plus de
250 jeunes adolescents québécois qui
s'initient au tabac et pour les
ministres du 6 charlebois
ce projet de loi donc et l'une
maintenant une loi est plus des plus
avancés au monde c'est pas rien et pour
ça bien sûr ça va compliquer la vie
des fumeurs il ya plusieurs mesures qui
vont entrer en vigueur graduellement
mais dès maintenant il est interdit donc
de fumer dans les endroits publics et
dans les endroits les établissements
publics également au niveau de la
cigarette électronique donc soumis aux
mêmes règles que la cigarette
traditionnelle dans six mois
trois mesures importantes vont entrer en
vigueur comme en ontario
il sera dorénavant interdit de fumer
dans une voiture lorsqu'un mineur est à
l'intérieur
les produits aromatisés vont être
retirés des tablettes est également il
sera interdit de fumer sur les terrasses
des restaurants et dans un an ce sont
les emballages donc les mises en garde
qui seront encore beaucoup plus
importante et enfin et ça ça va
constituer une première au canada les
pros mais les programmes de performance
de l'industrie du tabac qui incite les
commerçants à vendre leurs produits
seront dorénavant interdit alors vous
l'aurez deviné l'objectif ultime c'est
de réduire le nombre de fumeurs au
québec
et selon les projections d'ici cinq ans
emmanuel il y aura au moins 400 milles
fumeurs de moins au québec mais c'est
une bonne nouvelle et yves je le peux
vous quitter sans vous demander de nous
donner des nouvelles d'un tableau de
stephen harper qui à l'époque avait fait
tellement jaloux tellement jaser c'était
en 2012 c'était l'artiste margrethe
saturn qui avait imaginé
stephen harper nu parce que je vous
rassure il n'avait pas servi de modèle
pour cette toile elle avait fait
beaucoup de bruit parce qu'elle est
exposée dans une bibliothèque municipale
la dame qu'il l'avait acheté il avait
payé 5000 $ elle le revend maintenant
elle est à la retraite c'est un
fonctionnaire fédéral
elle revend le tableau est à la dernière
offre jusqu'à présent de 8800 dollars
pour le tableau en question
ceux qui seront intéressés pourront
aller le chercher je vous remercie
d'avoir été des nôtres
on vous remercie